bonsoir louis keumayou merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors appel
au boycott de l'opposition actes de
violence non participation de plusieurs
candidats un compte tenu du contexte les
résultats qui doivent être connus très
prochainement
est-ce qu'ils vont être ils vont être
accepté par la population
nous sommes dans une élection
présidentielle qui est qui se tient dans
un contexte vraiment très précaire non
seulement le président qui se présente
avait dit qu'il ne se représenterait pas
mais qu'il a dû le faire à la suite du
décès du premier ministre amadou gon
coulibaly qui a été désigné comme le
candidat de sa famille politique
et il ya eu tout ce débat qui a occulté
le le tout le débat sur le programme des
candidats celui sur l'anti
constitutionnalité d'une troisième
mandat possible alassane ouattara sac
c'est le premier contexte le deuxième
qu'il faut pas ignorer non plus c'est
qu'au sein même de la famille du rhdp
il ya eu beaucoup de défections il ya
notamment guillaume soro qui est le
patron de la branche armée qui est parti
il était présent à l'assemblée nationale
où il a quitté sa famille politique et à
d'autres membres de la coalition qui ont
quitté également le navire du rhdp
notamment haricots en belgique et qui
anciens présidents la culée ancien
président l'assemblée nationale
également
donc c'est un contexte dans lequel on
n'a pas eu un vrai débat politique on a
eu énormément de tension qui se sont
cristallisées et puis il faut pas
oublier pour les morts qui a eu avant
même le jour de l'élection et pendant
les élections tous les barrages qu'ils
aient pu empêcher l'élection de se tenir
et évidemment rien aussi ce mot d'ordre
nous désole sensible qui a été lancé par
l'opposition et qui a rendu très
compliqué la tenue du scrutin
donc c'est vrai que c'est une élection
qui n'est pas facile mais est-ce qu'on
pourrait annuler le résultat de cette
élection
l'enjeu est tel ou un point de vue
ailleurs parce que pour le président
ouattara
l'idée c'était de ne pas être dans
l'illégitimité politique en heure on
joue
au delà du délai constitutionnel qui lui
est accordée pour l'opposition il ne
fallait pas du tout que l'élection se
tienne donc les deux se sont battus
chacun avec les arguments qui étaient
les leurs et souvent même avec des
éléments qui relevait du vandalisme et
finalement l'élection a eu lieu on verra
la proclamation des résultats comment
les ivoiriens accueilleront cela
d'ivoire et des dieux bord parce que ce
n'est pas un bloc monolithique les
champs politiques sont très très
perceptible les champs ethnique
également dans dans les choix est donc
finalement c'est c'est un véritable bras
de fer qui va se manifester après le
résultat les urnes pour savoir si le
pays sera gouverné ou pas alors le parti
au pouvoir en attendant a mis en garde
l'opposition contre toute tentative de
déstabilisation
est ce que l'on peut craindre de réelles
tensions dans les jours qui vont venir
la tension est déjà là ce n'est pas pour
les jours à venir cela peut-être qu'il y
aura une montée en puissance de la
violence comme je le relevait tout à
l'heure et alicia toutes ces violences
qui a eu juste parce que il ya eu le
débat sur la constitutionnalité opa du
du troisième mandat d'alassane ouattara
qui a fait plus d'une trentaine de morts
il ya toutes les violences qui se sont
produites pendant les élections
et puis hier tout ce qui s'est fait en
marge de l'élection parce que les
maisons qui ont été collées dans
certaines régions il ya les violences
intercommunautaires qui se sont
également produites et ont débouché sur
la mort d'homme dont il ya déjà de la
violence
est ce qu'après cela un but qui a un
gouvernement de transition qui a été
fait un peu comme sur le modèle de celui
de l'hôtel du golf
quand le président ouattara revendiquer
sa victoire en 2010 et qu'il n'était pas
reconnue ni par la commission électorale
ni par la cour constitutionnelle y ait
une ouïe un gouvernant transition qui a
été monté en parallèle on verra comment
tout cela se passera mais c'est très
difficile
au moment où on se parle d'avoir une
projection clair les observateurs ont
des avis mitigés
cette commission dont on parle et indigo
cette association
elle a donné son pronostic mais elles
étaient accrédités sur nombre de bureaux
de vote à ses limites et au final parce
que c'est moins de 10% des bureaux de
vote
qui ont vu le passage de indigo et donc
que vos l'analyse d'indigo par rapport à
la situation globale sur les 94% des
bureaux de vote qui ne soit pas passée
de rien tous ces éléments qui font que
aujourd'hui on est dans une situation de
flou et je pense que les leaders
politiques devraient se comporter en
leader et essayer d'apaiser le climat
politique qui est de plus en plus tendue
alors vous parliez justement de cette
question constitutionnelle la
candidature d'alassane ouattara à un
troisième mandat
est ce qu'elle aurait pu être tranché
sereinement avant ces élections
non parce que la bataille est d'abord
interne ou rspp le lancement des
houphouétistes pour la démocratie et la
paix c'est l'intérieur de ce
rassemblement politique que la question
aurait dû être tranchée
l'alliance que alassane ouattara a fait
avec ses partenaires aussi bien
guillaume sourire que henri konan-bédié
et tous les autres membres du rhdp était
telle que le rdr qui le parti originel
d'alassane ouattara ne devait pas
présenter de candidat après 2015 c'est
ce qui se dit je n'ai pas d'éléments
pour le vérifier mais il était question
qui est au sein de la famille un passage
de relais
ce passage de relais n'a pas eu lieu et
donc c'est pour cette raison
principalement que le choix de amadou
gon coulibaly avait déjà été contestée
puis quand le président ouattara
lui-même a dû aller au charbon pour
défendre les couleurs de sa famille
politique ait eu encore des désistements
n'oublions pas que constitutionnellement
en côte d'ivoire il ya un premier
ministre
mais également vice président et que ce
vice-président là aujourd'hui a
démissionné n'a pas été remplacé donc il
ya un vrai débat au sein du rhdp pour
savoir il ya eu un débat pour savoir si
le président ouattara devait aller henri
konan-bédié a considéré qu non les
autres membres du rassemblement aussi et
donc du coup le président ouattara a
fait confiance à ceux qui le soutenaient
le plus et qui appelait à sa candidature
il l'a fait au détriment de l'alliance
que qui l'avait porté au pouvoir en 2006
merci beaucoup le oui que maille ou
d'avoir partager votre avis
je rappelle que vous êtes président du
club de l'information africaine